lille ça marchait un peu très bien
marché et je crois qu'il ya eu plus de
semble exemplaire en gros il doit y
avoir 40 mille ans petit mais si j'ai
bien été non cent quarante mille
exemples c'était le septième meilleur et
ses documents en 2001 alors qu'il est
sorti en octobre si tu te rappelles bien
donc il a battu même les livres qui s'en
sortir en janvier
c'était beau l'histoire étant d où l or
avec ton père mon père je pars tu vas
pas enrichi pas eu de contact est il
malgré le livre c'est moi je pensais
qu'après le livre pas mis à mon avis
c'était c'était quitte ou double parce
que c'était
c'est des choses quelqu'un me cacher
dans la famille que je moi je faisais en
sortir donc je pense par fierté gros
menteur tu deviennes oui je suis pas
rien mais bon enfant tu leur but j'ai
revu oui mais alors il va bien un conte
les oules elle est toujours toujours sur
la cotation
je veux voir de temps en temps bien mal
à voir plus souvent que ce que je vais
avoir mes
vous
j'adore j'adore j'aime beaucoup
travailler dans le stylisme tu veux plus
moi je gagne bien ma vie avec les
produits dérivés il tresse de l'argent
de ce que tu avais de ce que tu avais
gagné a love story le loft orbea cité on
devait acheter un bien immobilier avec
mon jeu mon appartement j'ai fait un
crédit quand même parce que ça m'a
permis que plus fier que le gain du loft
mais ça me fais ma petite tirelire
donc ce qui fait que chaque mot les
dépenser mais souvent je mets dans mon
crédit mais je me dis que ça va être un
petit un petit loto si jamais s'arrête
je vends mon appartement et j'aurai un
petit peu de tout de côté pour continuer
n'allez rural et ça a été une belle
histoire année dernière ne fait pas que
ses fils de jean noël vendent à moi son
père c'est un grand oui son père c'est
un grand séducteur mais je les rencontre
est un tout et il est l'extraordinaire
il y avait un hôtel son père ly selon le
commissaire louise promenade des anglais
actuellement ça oui et c'est fini oui en
fait on s'est rencontrés à la soirée
blanche et en juillet on nous plein
plein plein de points communs et donc
moi je les appelais en doute le fait pas
qu'est ce qu'il fait ou à doute il m'a
fait je suis chez papa-maman à nice et
moi je descendais voir maman j'ai passé
mon mois d'août aussi donc on a passé
tout le mois d'août ensemble et et après
le retour à paris était un petit peu dur
et puis surtout avec la presse on allait
acheter une carte postale y avait des
photographes ont d'aller faire une
balade ouais je crois que c'est ça qui
nous a tués raconte aurait été deux
inconnus auraient continué je crois
qu'on sera encore ensemble mais va venir
ce soir j'espère qu'il va vite et non
enfin jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans et j'ai
une belle reims quand je crois qu anna
qui commence directement dans une
famille un petit peu un peu en
difficulté mois jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans
maman était toujours à la maison j'ai
toujours eu des beaux noëls enfin de
belles familles j'ai remarqué un
téléralité suivant les gens à temps
souvent les gens sont soit un peu
fragile pour des histoires de parents ou
les histoires non on ne mais c'est la
société actuelle qui veut ça mais je
crois qu'un jour de carence forme
divorcé à l'école fin ouais ça doit bien
facilement sahin qui sait si vieira
bâle a justifié génial parce que c'était
vraiment sympa tu fais la connaissance
d'un document
c'est pas du tout abandonnée très
sympathique honda très simple
[Musique]
ouais tu t'es fait mal
messieurs bonsoir merci homme ça va
incroyable oui merci donc je vis des
pays les plus en vue il ya un an vous
n'êtes pas vu mais oui c'est ce que je
disais dernière fois c'était sur un
stand à la cuisine j'ai rien et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux